more signs of america's support for
ukraine on only his second visit to the
war zone since the conflict began more
than six months ago u.s secretary of
state anthony blinken made an
unannounced trip to key
blinken announced two billion dollars in
military assistance to ukraine and 18
countries in the region to counter what
he called russian aggression
also on thursday u.s defense secretary
lloyd austin in a visit to germany
announced a new
675 million dollar aid package for
ukraine
the pledges come as ukraine seems to
have gained momentum on the battlefield
at least in the north east where an
offensive against russian positions in
harkev region have shown early signs of
success
ukrainian forces say they have retaken
some 20 villages and towns and pushed
more than 50 kilometers past the front
lines into russian hill territory
videos from the front line seem to show
their units moving forward advancing on
russian entrenched positions
harkiev is the second largest city in
ukraine since the beginning of the war
it's remained firmly in ukrainian hands
however for months russia has controlled
much of the area to the east and south
the ukrainian advance appears to be
retaking all of harkiev to better
reinforce the defenses in the regional
capital
the ukrainians have clearly seized the
momentum in this war both with the visit
by america's top diplomat here to the
capitol with promises of more aid as
well as momentum on the battlefield with
clear territorial gains in the northeast
but this is also a war where momentum
can change quickly
gabriel zondo al jazeera keefe